mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
the angle between two rays is equal to
60 degrees
we will now construct three circles the
first circle is tangent to the two rays
the second circle is also tangent to the
two rays and its tangent to the first
circle
the third circle is tangent to the two
rays and change it to the second circle
if the radius of the first circle is
equal to one what is the radius of the
third circle equal to
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall if two circles are tangent their
centers and the tangent point are
collinear
to see why this is true suppose we have
circles a and b that are tangent at
point t
construct the tangent line through point
t
now a t
is perpendicular to this tangent line
and bt is also perpendicular to this
tangent line
therefore atb is a straight line segment
this is true for both externally and
internally tangent circles
now let's solve the problem
to make things a little bit easier to
see let's zoom in on these two smallest
circles
in the first circle construct one radius
to one point of tangency
this circle has a radius that's equal to
one
now construct another radius to the
other point of tangency
then connect the vertex of the rays to
the center of the small circle
we have now constructed two congruent
right angle triangles
this means the center line bisects the
angle between the rays meaning each of
these angles is equal to 30 degrees
from the second circle construct a
radius to one point of tangency
suppose this radius is equal to x
now connect the two centers of these two
circles
the distance between them will be equal
to one plus x
let's now just focus on these right
triangles
here we have a right angle triangle
where one angle is equal to 30 degrees
therefore we have a 30 60 90 special
right triangle
the shorter leg is equal to one and
therefore its hypotenuse will be equal
to twice that length or it's equal to 2.
we now have another 30-60-90 right
triangle
this is a similar triangle
so we know that the hypotenuse which is
equal to x plus 3 must be twice the
length of the shorter leg so this is
equal to 2 times x
we can then use this equation to solve
for x
we'll subtract x from both sides and we
just get that x is equal to three
so we've solved that the second circle
has a radius that's equal to three
we can now use this result to solve the
problem
notice that the second circle's radius
is exactly three times that of the
smaller circle's radius so it scales by
three
therefore we have a scale factor of
three
so we'll now go back to all three
circles
we'll zoom out
so the first circle has a radius that's
equal to one the second circle will have
a radius that's three times that which
is equal to three
therefore by proportionality the third
circle will have a radius that's three
times the length of the second circle's
radius so it will be equal to three
times three which is equal to nine
thus the radius of the third circle is
equal to nine and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you